en el vídeo pasado descubrimos algo que
parece como un problema con el ciclo de
calvin tenemos esta enorme proteína esta
enzima que facilita que suceda el ciclo
de calvin porque muchas de las moléculas
involucradas se enlazan con esta enzima
y después la enzima se dobla y provoca
que esas moléculas reaccionen de la
forma adecuada y bueno esta enzima se
llama rubisco rigurosa this post fato
carboxilasa oxygen nasa y bueno cuando
el ciclo de calvin está funcionando de
forma adecuada tenemos aquí dióxido de
carbono que se enlaza en algún lugar de
esta enzima y luego tenemos también vp
que es rigurosa 1.5 bis fosfato enlazada
también en alguna parte de esta enzima y
estos van a reaccionar y si todo está
saliendo bien con el ciclo de calvin van
a reaccionar van a ser aplastados
juntados y luego separados y van a
terminar formando otras moléculas y aquí
tenemos un
molécula de dióxido de carbono y una
molécula de rubí y siempre que tengamos
una de estas y una de estas vamos a
obtener dos moléculas llamadas tres
fósforo glee cerato ahora en el vídeo
pasado empecé con tres de estas y tres
de estas y obtuvimos seis de estas pero
ahora estamos empezando con una de estas
y una de estas y entonces obtenemos dos
de éstas
y si este es el ciclo de kelvin sin
ninguna alteración estas moléculas se
convierten en dos moléculas de tres
fósforo visceral de ido o sea en
moléculas p gal y ahora cada que
producimos seis de estos cinco se
utilizan para reconstruir tres moléculas
de rubén aunque para hacer las cosas más
claras me parece que lo mejor sería
poner por aquí un 3 así es que tenemos
que cambiar todos estos números si
tenemos 3 rubén péez necesitamos 3
dióxido de carbono y con esto producimos
63 fósforo lideratos por lo cual
obtenemos 6 fósforo glicerol de y dos de
los cuales 55 bègles se regresan para
reconstruir tres moléculas de rube y el
otro que queda podríamos decir que es el
producto final de la fotosíntesis y que
lo podemos utilizar para hacer otras
cosas cómo construir carbohidratos
es que obtenemos un pegar ahora el
problema que observamos en el vídeo
pasado es que la enzima rubisco no sólo
fija al dióxido de carbono esta enzima
también puede hacer que reaccione una
molécula de oxígeno podríamos
encontrarnos con alguna molécula de
oxígeno la cual también se puede enlazar
sobre la enzima rubisco y reaccionar con
la rigurosa this post facto haciendo
otro ciclo al que le llamamos la foto
respiración y como estamos diciendo que
tenemos tres rigurosas be fosfato
tenemos tres moléculas de oxígeno y
juntos van a producir no seis sino tres
fósforo lideratos pero también van a
producir otros tres fosfórico latos
fosfórico lato el cual es un producto
que se va a procesar más adelante en
algún otro órgano de la célula y luego
como aquí tenemos tres fósforos
literatos aquí únicamente vamos a tener
tres pedales
es que no podemos usar uno de ellos para
la construcción de carbohidratos porque
ni siquiera vamos a tener suficientes
pedales como para reconstruir todas las
rigurosas bis fosfatos que utilizamos en
este ciclo y además además en este ciclo
utilizamos un montón de moléculas de atp
y dna de ph así es que esto es un
verdadero problema si hay un montón de
oxígeno o bueno si hay por lo menos un
poco de oxígeno en el ambiente va a
provocar esta situación ineficiente
porque de vez en cuando van a llegar
estos oxígenos a la enzima rubisco y se
va a dar
este ciclo de foto respiración cuando en
realidad lo que necesitamos es dióxido
de carbono para poder producir estos
carbohidratos así es que como le hacen
las plantas para resolver este problema
bueno pues una solución es hacer el
ciclo de calvin en un ambiente en el que
haya muy poco oxígeno
incluso hasta podríamos decir que es un
ambiente en el que no haya oxígeno
esto es exactamente lo que hacen algunas
plantas y en este momento tal vez puedes
preguntar me oye pero como le hacen las
plantas se tienen que ir a otro planeta
donde no haya oxígeno ok y no la verdad
es que hacen algo muy ingenioso pero
para entender lo tenemos que ver un poco
de la anatomía de la planta y eso va a
estar muy bien porque últimamente hemos
visto pura bioquímica y ver unas hojas
por aquí va a estar divertido y de hecho
sobre la superficie de la hoja y bueno
de hecho sobre las dos superficies hay
estos pequeños agujeros a lo largo de
toda la superficie estos pequeños poros
estos agujeros se llaman esto más y
estos agujeros no son tan grandes como
los dibuje aquí
de hecho necesitarías un microscopio
para poder observarlos y se llaman esto
más y es por aquí por donde el aire
entra por donde ingresa el dióxido de
carbono principalmente y también un poco
de oxígeno y también por donde se libera
el vapor de agua ahora
si dibujara mos una sección transversal
y dejame la dibujo por aca este de aquí
sería el estómago aunque éste sería el
poro de la hoja y de hecho casi todas
las plantas pueden abrir y cerrar su
estómago vamos a hablar de eso más
adelante pero ahorita lo que más me
interesa es que veamos qué es lo que
está sucediendo adentro de la hoja para
la mayoría de las plantas el proceso de
fotosíntesis se da en las células de las
capas de enmedio llamadas células del
mes o phil o lo que hay por aquí está el
mesófilo que son las capas de enmedio y
en algún lugar de la página hay un vídeo
muy detallado acerca de la anatomía de
las hojas de las plantas pero por el
momento vamos a dibujar sin mucha
precisión por aquí a las células del mes
o phil o aquí en estas células es donde
sucede la fotosíntesis generalmente en
las células del mes o film
aquí es donde generalmente sucede la
fotosíntesis pero
ahora como para hacer la fotosíntesis
necesitan el dióxido de carbono
generalmente no están acomodadas como
las dibuje aquí si es que vamos a borrar
esto de hecho generalmente tienen algo
de espacio entre ellas para que pueda
fluir el aire libremente en esta
situación el aire puede entrar por el
estómago
y llegar a todas las células del mes o
fila y cuando digo aire me refiero a
aire que está compuesto por oxígeno
dióxido de carbono nitrógeno y algunas
otras cosas pero por supuesto estas
células del mes o filo necesitan el
dióxido de carbono para poder hacer el
ciclo de calvin ahora estas células no
sólo están obteniendo dióxido de carbono
si ese fuera el caso entonces no
tendríamos ningún problema no nos
preocuparíamos acerca de la foto
respiración pero el problema es que
también están recibiendo oxígeno así es
que qué puede hacer la planta para
prevenir este problema y no me refiero a
todas las plantas la mayoría de las
plantas simplemente lidian con la foto
respiración que es menos eficiente de lo
ideal pero hay algunas plantas que
podríamos decir que han evolucionado
para arreglar el problema de la foto
respiración ya estas plantas les
llamamos c4 porque realizan la
fotosíntesis
también conocida como la vía de 4
carbonos la ruta de 4 o la vía de
hasluck pero bueno aquí le vamos a
llamar fotosíntesis c4 espero que en
unos cuantos minutos te des cuenta de
por qué le llamamos así pero bueno
regresemos a lo que teníamos por acá en
el ciclo de kelvin clásico el primer
subproducto es el fósforo y cerato el
cual es una cadena de 3 carbonos así es
que la primera vez que fijas al dióxido
de carbono y bueno de hecho también la
primera vez que fijas al oxígeno la
primera molécula que obtienes es una
cadena de 3 carbonos y por eso es que a
esto se le llama fotosíntesis c3 grave
fotosíntesis c3 y esto es una pista si
nos regresamos por acá esto seguramente
nos está diciendo que la primera vez que
fijamos al carbono en la fotosíntesis c4
obtenemos una molécula de 4 carbonos y
ahora si ya llegamos a la parte
interesante tenemos por aquí todas
las células del mes off y lo que están
obteniendo dióxido de carbono y oxígeno
y cualquier otra cosa que se encuentra
en el aire tenemos todas estas células
del mes o fila pero también tenemos
estas otras células que están un poco
más adentro en lo más profundo de la
hoja en donde no están expuestas
directamente al aire que entra por los
estomas y se llaman células de la vaina
de las vascular y de hecho son las
células que rodean al haz vascular que
es el conducto por el cual la planta
transporta sus fluidos y por supuesto
vamos a hacer un vídeo completo acerca
de la anatomía de las plantas pero por
el momento lo que queremos es entender
qué es lo que sucede en la fotosíntesis
c4 así es que tenemos estas otras
células que están un poco más profundo
adentro de la planta que ya no están en
contacto directo con el aire que entra
por los estomas y que se llaman células
de la vaina del haz vascular
y células de la vaina del haz vascular
en el ciclo de calvin típico todo sucede
en las células del mes o fila y tienes
que lidiar con el oxígeno y con la foto
respiración pero en las plantas se 4
cuando las plantas están haciendo
fotosíntesis c4 lo que sucede es que el
dióxido de carbono llega a las células
del mes o phil o aunque hay todo esto
está sucediendo en el mesófilo que son
estas células de aquí en el mesófilo
llega el dióxido de carbono pero aquí en
lugar de reaccionar con rubí o sea con
la rigurosa 15 bis fosfato reacciona con
otra molécula que también tiene un
nombre muy complicado y que en general
nos vamos a referir a ella simplemente
como p pero que se llama fos fenol
piruvato y bueno es una cadena de 3
carbono aunque bueno la verdad no
estaría nada mal poner el nombre por
aquí
foss fenol piruvato o también conocido
como así
fosrenol piruvato es una cadena de 3
carbonos por supuesto tiene algunas
otras cosas por aquí pero lo que ahorita
nos interesan son los carbonos y es una
cadena de 3 carbonos pero ahora cuando
reaccionan estos dos que es lo que nos
va a quedar por aquí
bueno pues podemos empezar a adivinar
por aquí tenemos un carbono y por acá
tenemos otros 3 carbonos así es que
vamos a terminar con una cadena de 4
carbonos pero ahora esta reacción no es
facilitada por la enzima rubisco por la
enzima tribu los a bis fosfato
carboxilasa oxigenas a esto es
facilitado por otra enzima y esa es la
clave de la fotosíntesis c4 esta es otra
enzima que de hecho se llama pep
carboxilasa que esta enzima se llama pep
carboxilasa y de hecho es un nombre muy
bueno porque recuerda por ejemplo el
nombre de rubisco es rigurosa bis
fosfato carboxilasa
oxygen nasa y la enzima rubisco hacía
que la riva los abismos pato reaccionará
con el carbono y con el oxígeno por eso
tenemos aquí las palabras carboxilasa y
oxigena za pero ahora por acá tenemos
una enzima que hace que reaccione
nuestra molécula pep únicamente con el
dióxido de carbono y es por eso que se
llama pep carboxilasa y la razón por la
que es súper importante y súper útil
contra la foto respiración es porque
sólo reacciona con el dióxido de carbono
y no con el oxígeno ok
solo fije al carbono y no a fija al
oxígeno así es que podemos imaginarnos
por aquí todo esto está sucediendo en
las células del mes o fila y el dióxido
de carbono y el oxígeno están flotando
por ahí pero únicamente el dióxido de
carbono puede reaccionar con el pp a
través de la pep carboxilasa y una vez
que reaccionan forman al ácido
exhaló acético también conocido como ox
al acetato ox al acetato y está súper
bien si te acuerdas de esta molécula del
ciclo de krebs que por cierto es la
primera especie reactiva del ciclo de
krebs y bueno todo este tipo de
moléculas siguen apareciendo una y otra
vez en nuestras vías químicas porque
están interconectadas lo cual es
bastante interesante pero aquí lo
importante es que estos forman ox al
acetato y luego el ox al acetato se
convierte ya sea en malato o en
aspartato ok en ácido málico o ácido
aspártico pero el punto es que se
convierte en otra molécula de 4 carbonos
estas son cadenas de 4 carbonos van a
ser un poco diferentes algunas tendrán
más oxígenos o hidrógeno pero esto de
aquí es o malato o aspartato muchos
libros simplemente dicen que se
convierte en malato ahora eventualmente
el malato va a reaccionar para formar
dióxido de carbono y aquí tú no puedes
decir oye espérame tantito primero
empiezas con dióxido de carbono y luego
lo fijas formando ox al acetato que
después se transforma en malato o
aspartato y finalmente esto libera
dióxido de carbono cuál es el punto de
todo esto y justo esta es la clave del
asunto porque este malato si se va a
convertir en pp y en dióxido de carbono
y aquí nos preguntamos oye pero cuál fue
el punto de toda esta reacción si
terminamos con los mismos compuestos con
pep y dióxido de carbono y aquí podría
volver a empezar el ciclo y estaríamos
dando vueltas en círculos pero la cosa
super interesante acerca de esto y qué
es lo que previene que suceda la foto
respiración es que esta parte sucede en
la célula del mesófilo lo que sucede por
aquí en la célula del mesófilo
sin mal dato pero el mal dato es
transportado a las células de la vaina
de las vascular el mal hato se
transporta a las células de la vaina de
las vascular a través de unos pequeños
tubos entre las paredes celulares de
estas células llamados plasmo des moss
que hay aquí tenemos unos tubos que
conectan a estas células y ahora lo
vamos a dibujar con más detalle por acá
tenemos a la célula del mesófilo que
está expuesta al aire y esta célula está
en contacto con el oxígeno y con el
dióxido de carbono y con todos los
elementos del aire pero únicamente el
dióxido de carbono puede ser fijado con
pepe porque tenemos por aquí el pp
fósforo en el piruvato pp
únicamente el dióxido de carbono puede
reaccionar con pep porque en estas
células del mes o phil o la enzima que
opera speed carboxilasa que es muchísimo
más específica que la enzima rubisco
logra que la enzima rívolo xavi fosfato
carboxilasa oxigena za y el oxígeno es
simplemente ignorado aunque esté aquí
flotando en la célula y luego éstas se
transforman en oxalato el cual se
convierte a su vez en mal dato o
aspartato y luego el mal dato es
transportado a un lugar más profundo es
transportado a una célula que se
encuentra en un lugar más profundo a
través de estos tubos llamados plasma
des moss esta célula del mesófilo es
bastante probable que esté aplastada
contra una célula de la vaina del haz
vascular entonces vamos a poner por aquí
una de esas célula
esta es la célula de la vaina del haz
vascular que quedó pegadito a esta
célula del mesófilo y esta no tiene
acceso al oxígeno por aquí tenemos el
plasma desmo y aquí simplemente vamos a
dibujar uno pero ahora el malato va a
pasar a través de este tubo y aquí en
esta célula más profunda en esta célula
de la vaina del haz vascular el malato
puede reaccionar para formar dióxido de
carbono y piruvato y una vez que ya
tenemos el piruvato por aquí este puede
ser regresado a la célula del mesófilo
para volver a construir una molécula pp
un fósforo el piruvato y el punto
importante aquí es que en esta célula de
la vaina vascular tenemos un ambiente en
el que únicamente hay dióxido de carbono
y no oxígeno básicamente lo que hicimos
por seleccionar al dióxido de carbono
del exterior o bueno del aire al que
tienen acceso a las células del mes o
phil o
ahora en un nivel más profundo de la
hoja tenemos un ambiente en el que
únicamente hay dióxido de carbono porque
aquí estuve seleccionando para que sólo
pasara el dióxido de carbono y ahora que
estamos en esta célula más profunda en
esta célula de la vaina del haz vascular
podemos fijar al dióxido de carbono
porque hay tomamos la riva los avisos
fato vp y con ella fijamos al dióxido de
carbono con la ayuda de la enzima
rubisco de la misma forma como
aprendimos en el ciclo de calvin
original y aquí tenemos todo nuestro
ciclo y producimos nuestros azúcares o
bueno producimos que 3p opergal como sea
que le quieras llamar y con ellos
producimos azúcares ahora aquí lo
importante es que ya no tenemos foto
respiración porque aquí estamos haciendo
el ciclo de calvin en un ambiente en el
que únicamente hay dióxido de carbono y
me parece que ya lo mencioné pero
a esto se le llama fotosíntesis c4 y en
términos generales es una adaptación
para asegurarse que no pierdas ciclos de
calvin en esto de la foto respiración y
por supuesto se llama c4 porque la
primera vez que se fija al carbono no
sucede aquí en el ciclo de calvin sino
sucede por acá con el pp y el dióxido de
carbono y el pp carboxilasa que junto a
estos dos para formar una cadena de 4
carbonos y por eso es por lo que se
llama fotosíntesis c4